beruht zwischen trauer und wut tausende
protestieren gegen ihre regierung
demonstranten stürmen das
außenministerium testpflicht für
reiserückkehrer
ab jetzt gilt wer aus einem risikogebiet
nach deutschland kommt muss sich auf
corona testen lassen und sommersonne
pandemie das heiße wetter treibt viele
an die küste an den stränden wird es
ziemlich eng
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten am samstag auch
norbert lehmann ist wieder dabei er hat
wenig später den sport für uns ein
wunder durch von mir nach beirut wo sich
die menschen nach der verheerenden
explosion von der regierung völlig im
stich gelassen fühlen die wut auf die
politiker denen sie die schuld an der
katastrophe geben wird immer größer
heute protestierten wieder tausende
gegen die regierung und forderten ihren
sturz einige besetzten sogar das
außenministerium und erklärten es zum so
wörtlich hauptquartier der revolution
lück walpert nach dem entsetzen der zorn
tausende zogen am nachmittag ins zentrum
von beirut mit lauten sprechchören
revolution bis wie sie verjagt haben
es sind viele junge libanesen
studentinnen und studenten darunter wie
der politikerkaste des landes vorwerfen
durch vetternwirtschaft und korruption
die explosionskatastrophe ermöglicht zu
haben
die sitzen da oben in ihren sesseln
während wir hier vor zerstörten häusern
und existenzen stehen
die sollen abtreten alle immer wieder
versuchten aufgebrachte demonstranten
zum parlamentsgebäude vorzudringen
die sicherheitskräfte setzten tränengas
ein die stimmung war sehr aufgeheizt
auch schüsse waren nach medienberichten
zu hören vor einer stunde dann gelangten
demonstranten in das gebäude des
außenministeriums unterdessen sicherte
eu-ratspräsident michelle bei seinem
besuch in beirut den libanesen die hilfe
der europäischen union beim wiederaufbau
zu aber michelle mahnte auch
tiefgreifende reformen an
das sind dringend politische und
finanzielle reformen erforderlich um die
korruption in diesem land wirksam zu
bekämpfen
wie schwierig das werden könnte deutete
der chef der arabischen liga bei seinem
besuch in beirut in diplomatischen
worten an
der status des libanon das müssen wir
einräumen ist kompliziert und schwierig
die zahl der todesopfer der explosion
stieg inzwischen nach amtlichen angaben
auf 158 fragen wir unseren
korrespondenten uli gack vor ort in
beirut was hat das zu bedeuten oli die
erstürmung des außenamts ist das
tatsächlich der beginn einer revolution
ich glaube schon es wurde nicht nur das
außenministerium gestürmt sondern so
eben auch das finanzministerium haben
wird gehört es soll auch der
premierminister vorgezogene wahlen
angekündigt haben aber das interessiert
hier eigentlich niemand weil niemand
diese regierung glaubt es ist jetzt hier
momentan änderung viel tränengas in der
luft und die frage ist wie lange werden
die sicherheitskräfte das militär noch
loyal zur regierung stellen und weitere
angriffe hier aufs parlamentsgebäude
beispielsweise abwehren
das land ist pleite wenn die gehälter
für polizei militär nicht mehr bezahlt
werden muss man davon ausgehen dass das
militär von der fahne geht und dann
herrscht hier absolute anarchie die
revolutionäre das haben kein programm
sie sagen nicht wie ihre künftige
regierung aussieht sie wollen nur eines
dieser alte regierung ablösen und das
möglichst schnell
vielen dank für ihre informationen uniqa
kaders aus beirut 300.000 menschen
sollen obdachlos sein in beirut zur
unterstützung der bevölkerung ist die
internationale hilfe angelaufen
auch das deutsche rote kreuz hat in
berlin ein flugzeug mit 43 tonnen
hilfsgütern beladen darunter erste hilfe
sets und verbandsmaterial mit an bord
aber auch coop 19 masken und
schutzanzügen der flieger soll noch
heute nacht in beirut landen wenn sie
den menschen in not helfen wollen können
sie das gerne tun und spenden und zwar
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe libanon bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
finden sie auch unter spenden punkt
zdf.de oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
ab heute gilt sie
die testpflicht für urlaubs rückkehrer
aus risikogebieten
aktuell gelten rund 130 staaten als
risikogebiete von den usa über südafrika
bis nach chile
auch bei deutschen touristen beliebte
urlaubsländer sind darunter wie die
türkei oder ägypten zu den
risikogebieten zählt das robert koch
institut aber auch viele balkan-staaten
wie serbien und drei regionen in
nordspanien testen lassen müssen sich
reisende bei der rückkehr nach
deutschland oder noch im urlaub
peter theißen der andrang groß an den
beiden test centern am frankfurter
flughafen registrieren anmelden dann der
abstrich die meisten sind in einer
viertelstunde durch nasenabstrich
erwartet aber sicherheit geht vor
ich finds gut weil meine eltern sind
risikogruppe und wenn ich jetzt nach
hause gehen und leute treffen wollte
dann bin ich ganz froh wenn ich aus der
quarantäne früher raus kommen dank des
tests
um die 2500 menschen kommen derzeit
täglich aus risikogebieten am
frankfurter flughafen an testen lassen
sich aber auch viele reisende aus dem
eu-ausland freiwillig ja sehen dass in
den letzten tagen die anzahl der
positiven angestiegen ist wir sind bei
etwa anderthalb prozent positiven
inzwischen und überwiegende anteil 80
prozent davon die aus dem europäischen
ausland zurückgekommen sind
spätestens am nächsten tag liegt das
testergebnis vor eine momentaufnahme die
auch viele beim grenzübergang von tirol
nach bayern wünschen
trotz brüllender hitze und wartezeiten
machen heute dort 1500 menschen
freiwillig einen test zwischenstopp wir
haben angst davor dass es tatsächlich
krieg gekriegt haben am gardasee deshalb
wenn wir es hier machen können bevor was
in düsseldorf machen
ich sehe es als meine pflicht dass es
macht also von dem her mehr kinder als
er von dem er ich habe eltern zu hause
ist eigentlich selbstverständlich und
für alle reisenden aus risikogebieten
gilt bei test verweigerung drohen bis zu
25.000 euro strafe auf der warnliste des
auswärtigen amtes stehen jetzt auch
teile von bulgarien und rumänien wegen
steigender fallzahlen die reisewarnung
gilt für insgesamt zehn regionen dort
darunter der auch bei deutschen
touristen beliebte goldstrand an der
bulgarischen schwarzmeerküste
was die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland angeht liegt diese bereits
den dritten tag in folge bei mehr als
1000 das robert koch institut meldet
1122 neue corona fälle im schnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich laut
johns hopkins universität täglich 830
menschen neu angesteckt gestern waren es
790 die zahlen zeigen dass sich wieder
mehr menschen in deutschland infizieren
und experten mahnen an die abstands und
hygiene regeln zu befolgen das kann an
diesem wochenende zur herausforderung
werden denn ob an badeseen oder an
küsten vielerorts war es wegen der hitze
richtig eng
anselm stern
anstehen für die abkühlung das meer hier
die ostsee bei scharbeutz in
schleswig-holstein zufluchtsort an
diesen hitze wochenende schnell ist es
so richtig voll
immer wieder müssen ganze
strandabschnitte geschlossen werden denn
da ist ja noch die virus krise ich habe
meine maske mit dabei aber die leute
legen alle trotzdem ist so voll ist doch
echt gut auf abstand muss ich sagen ich
verstehe das nicht da ich schon wirklich
kein platz mehr
und trotzdem einer nach dem anderen
kommt darauf obwohl eine lange schlange
ist obwohl alles so ist also schön ist
das nicht mehr
aber es geht auch anders die
allermeisten beispielsweise hier in
mecklenburg vorpommern verlieren auch im
erholungsmodus nicht die achtsamkeit ich
gucke schon nach der abstand ist mir
jemand du dich kommt oder so eine
bildershow ein bisschen abstand halten
könnte umsichtig sind sowieso die
lebensretter der dlrg ganz besonders in
zeiten der distanz wir kontrollieren die
abstände jetzt sage ich mal nicht mit
einem maßband wir gucken schon dass das
in etwa passt so weit wie das alte
machbar ist und wenn abstände absolut
nicht eingehalten werden halten wir
rücksprache mit dem ordnungsamt schwer
ist das mit dem abstand wenn
schwimmbäder und seen schwer beliebt
sind lange schlangen vor einigen bädern
bei weit mehr als 30 grad
hier in der nähe von erfurt sind heute
viele extra früh aufgestanden und damit
man reinkommt so ist das dann mit der
erholung an diesen heißen tagen in virus
zeiten
nach osteuropa in belarus auch bekannt
als weißrussland wählen die menschen
morgen einen neuen präsidenten oder eine
neue präsidentin
seit 26 jahren wird das land von
alexander lukaschenko autoritär regiert
hoffnungsträgerin der opposition es wird
sicher noch ska 37 jahre alt gelernte
übersetzerin politisch unerfahren in den
letzten wochen kamen tausende menschen
zu ihren veranstaltungen filme gar über
1100 festnahmen gab es seit mai bei
wahlveranstaltungen der opposition
das meldet die belarussische
menschenrechtsorganisation wesna und
trotzdem fordern die menschen weiter
lautstark veränderungen gestern abend in
minsk als fahrrad kolonne die
fahrradfahrer und das gefällt mir sind
in diesem jahr aktiv in der bewegung und
zeigen ihre unzufriedenheit mit dem was
im land passiert sehr lange herrschte
bei uns die meinung dass bemühungen
aktiv zu handeln nutzlos sind wir
versuchen das gegenteil zu beweisen
wieder gibt es festnahmen störung der
öffentlichen ordnung oder fehlender
rückspiegel die gründe erscheinen
beliebig es ist die immer gleiche
reaktion des systems lukaschenko das
nicht mit ihr gerechnet hat svetlana die
hanowski eigentlich wollte ihr mann ein
populärer blogger antreten
er wurde zu beginn des wahlkampfs
behaftet svetlana übernahm
unterstützt wird sie von zwei weiteren
frauen der partnerin eines kandidaten
der ins ausland fliehen musste und der
mitarbeiterin eines
präsidentschaftsanwärter der in u-haft
kam ein großes meine anhänger wählen
eine normale person die ihnen
versprochen hat innerhalb eines halben
jahres faire wahlen zu organisieren
damit ein echter politiker den
präsidentensessel übernehmen kann
ein wirtschaftsexperte der unser land
nach vorne bringt unter demokratischen
umständen wäre tier an oskar ja eine
aussichtsreiche herausforderin doch
lukaschenko hat bisher noch immer wege
gefunden an der macht zu bleiben
mauritius bekannt für seine lagunen und
riffe steht vor einer katastrophe ein
ölteppich breitet sich vor der küste aus
mit dramatischen folgen für tiere und
pflanzen für die ganze insel zwei wochen
ist es her dass ein frachter hier vor
der südostküste auf grund lief dann riss
sein rumpf und nun fließt das öl
ungehindert in den ozean tim kröger höhe
von mauritius dem inselparadies im
indischen ozean
die weißen strände das türkise wasser
die meeresfauna all das ist hier an der
südostseite bedroht vor zwei wochen lief
der frachter wacker chemie aus noch
unbekannter ursache auf das riff nun
breitet sich ein schwarzer teppich aus
tausende tonnen öl könnten naheliegende
naturschutzgebiete in der lagune
verdrecken mit 400 schwimmenden sperren
sollen sie geschützt werden das öl wird
eingefangen und dann abgepumpt es ist
ein rennen gegen die zeit bevor noch
mehr austritt wo soll ich es ist richtig
dass wir versuchen das schiff zu
stabilisieren aber dafür müssen wir erst
mal die notwendige ausrüstung die
richtigen schlepper auf mauritius finden
die behörden befürchten dass sich am
sonntag das wetter verschlechtert der
inselstaat hat den umweltnotstand
ausgerufen
schon die korona pandemie macht der
tourismusbranche zu schaffen auf die die
1,3 millionen einwohner angewiesen sind
eine größere ölkatastrophe könnte die
situation noch verschlimmern
jetzt in die eifel zur rennstrecke am
legendären nürburgring dem mekka für
motorsportfans war jedoch jahrzehntelang
auch die formel 1 zu gast
sechs jahre allerdings war pause im
oktober kehrt die formel 1 zurück ob
trotz corona mit tausenden zuschauern
darüber ist ein streit entbrannt ein
oldtimer rennen dient als testlauf
christopher heinz
motoren gebrüll live vor ort erleben zum
ersten mal in diesem jahr ist das am
nürburgring möglich bis zu 5000
zuschauer pro tag dürfen beim oldtimer
grand prix auf die tribünen dank
ausnahmegenehmigung der kreisverwaltung
arbeiten eigentlich sind laut der
rheinland-pfälzischen corona bekämpfung
verordnung nur 350 personen zulässig
diese veranstaltung kann ein testlauf
eine blaupause für alle kommenden
veranstaltungen seien
das ist mit sicherheit die formel 1 im
oktober aber vorher haben wir noch
andere veranstaltungen wie zum beispiel
dtm 24 stunden rennen das kann
funktionieren dass das adaptierbar ist
dass der testlauf auch tatsächlich
funktioniert dafür soll das hygiene
konzept sorgen zusammen mit der uni bonn
entwickelt vom parkplatz über die
tribüne bis zum sitzplatz alles ist
personalisierte tickets gibt es nur
online auf der tribüne dann sind nur
kleingruppen von vier personen zulässig
mit abstand dazwischen
trotz all dieser regelungen kommt kritik
vom rheinland-pfälzischen
gesundheitsministerium
ausgehend von der tatsache dass unsere
krone bekämpfung verordnung derzeit 350
menschen im freien zulässt ist das hier
natürlich eine vervielfachung der
zulässigen teilnehmerzahl so dass wir
dann schon auch dem landkreis deutlich
gemacht haben dass wir damit so unsere
probleme haben
bislang sind etwas mehr als 3000 in die
eifel gekommen
ob im oktober zur formel 1 überhaupt
zuschauer zugelassen werden ist derzeit
nicht absehbar dafür muss ich das jetzt
der probte konzept das funktionstüchtig
erweisen und auch das
infektionsgeschehen muss dann
überschaubar sein und vom nürburgring zu
einer anderen großen traditionsstrecke
der formel eins nämlich der in
silverstone ja da wird 70 jahre formel 1
gefeiert morgen der jubiläums grand prix
heute beim qualifying die
mercedes-piloten bottas und hamilton
fahren vettel dem ferrari nur auf platz
12 aber ein deutscher hatte grund zum
jubeln nico hülkenberg er ist die
derzeit glücklichste teilzeitkraft im
formel 1 geschäft nico hülkenberg der
ersatzmann für sergio perez im racing
point glänzt bei seinem qualifying
einsatz drittschnellste zeit
noch perfekter läuft es wie so oft für
mercedes die silberpfeile momentan eine
klasse für sich heute hat valtteri
bottas im ziel die nase vorne vor
teamkollege lewis hamilton 63
hundertstel der vorsprung für sebastian
vettel ende das qualifying wie erwartet
nur rang zwölf die ratlosigkeit im
ferrari team scheint immer größer zu
werden
start der deutschen
leichtathletik-meisterschaften in
braunschweig ohne zuschauer und mit
strengem hygiene konzept und einigen
stars darunter die wm-dritte gesa
felicitas krause die überraschend
aufgeben musste es sind nicht 3000 meter
es sind kaum 2000 die wm-dritte gesa
felicitas krause scheidet auf dem weg
zum sechsten nationalen titel aus heute
hat irgendwie das training von den
letzten wochen meine beine
runtergedrückt die wärme ja irgendwie
nicht mein tag also auf den punkt haben
wir leider also mein trainer und ich
diesmal nicht hinbekommen die
rekordhalterin total indisponiert gerade
aus dem höhentrainingslager nach
braunschweig gekommen
wir sind keine maschinen werden nicht
irgendwie eingestellt das ist einfach
alles funktioniert also es sind viele
kleine stellschrauben an denen immer
wieder gedreht werden muss
das erste mal deutsche meisterin elena
burkard aus dem nordschwarzwald im
gegensatz zu ihr diesmal ein trauriger
tag für gesa krause
fußball-champions-league der
italienische und spanische meister sind
im achtelfinale ausgeschieden juventus
turin mit superstar ronaldo gegen
olympique lyon heute die entlassung von
juve-trainer sari und real madrid
unterliegt manchester city ein abend zum
vergessen für raphael varane reals
innenverteidiger der französische
nationalspieler leitete bei der 1
2-niederlage gegen city beide gegentore
ein
den ersten fehler nutzt dörling in der
neunten gabriel jesus den zweiten in der
68 minute madrids einziger treffer durch
benzema zum zwischenzeitlichen ausgleich
zu wenig nach dem 1 2 im hinspiel
real mit toni kroos ausgeschieden für
city und trainer pep guardiola geht es
beim finalturnier in lissabon mit der
runde der letzten acht gegen lyon weiter
und über einen letzten acht gefühlt als
heute abend barcelona gegen neapel und
bayern gegen chelsea sein kinowelt
morgen sind erste hitzegewitter möglich
dazu erneut bis 38 grad heiß die details
gleich beim wetter von tally so viel von
uns später am abend um 22 uhr 45
erwartet sie marietta slomka zum heute
journal
schön dass sie dabei waren und
hoffentlich auch morgen wieder
einschalten um 19 uhr einen angenehm und
nicht zu warm abend für sie
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter viel sonnenschein
gab es heute aber auch erste harmlose
quellwolken die sehen sie hier in weiß
die kopten besonders über den bergen auf
und morgen können diese noch höher
wachsen und dann sich zu gewittern
entwickeln
das sind dann aber nur einzelne gewitter
schauen wir uns erst mal die nachbarn im
norden gibt es harmlose wolken sonst ist
es meist sternenklar und trocken die
temperaturen sinken auf 23 grad im
westen im osten auf 20 grad die
innenstädte kühlen kaum ab 12 grad gibt
es am alpenrand
morgen dann im tagesverlauf wieder viel
sonne und dann zum nachmittag querungen
und da kann es durchaus zu einzelnen
gewitter kommen hauptsächlich über den
bergen im süden scheint verbreitet die
sonne bei temperaturen bis zu 38 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet und 25 grad an der
ostsee das ist die temperaturspanne die
waldbrandgefahr ist ziemlich hoch
zurzeit teilweise die maximale stufe 5
vor allem in brandenburg ist es ziemlich
extrem aber auch sonst haben wir sehr
hohe werte bis 4
wir schauen auf die aussichten und da
gibt es in den nächsten tagen einzelne
gewitter die können vor allem über den
bergen entstehen meist temperaturen von
25 bis 36 grad
ein schöner abend